today is america recycles day and we
want to look at just how good of a job
southern nevadans are doing in reducing
waste in our landfill by recycling and
ask you if you know which items can and
can't be thrown in that blue cart for
recycling so we're going straight to the
source this morning communications
manager for republic services jeremy
walters gives us a little recycling 101.
you know when it comes to recycling what
are some of the biggest mistakes that
we're making jeremy
sherry you know the single biggest
problem that we see here in southern
nevada and all across the u.s
is flexible plastics these things wrap
and tangle around the sorting equipment
whether it's a bag it's the packaging
inside your amazon box and then add in
the layer that sometimes people bag
their good recyclables we're trying to
sort one thing at a time so if you're
bagging your recyclables you're actually
hindering the process
jeremy says the sorting process flows
smoother on their end if we keep bottles
cans and paper loose in the blue bin and
also empty clean and dry
the reason that we ask you to do that is
because you know cardboard and paper
it's great for recycling but only if
it's clean and dry if that milk or pasta
sauce or soup or juice
spills on paper and cardboard it's
soiled and we now have to throw it away
and while we buy products made with and
packaged in a variety of plastic grades
they can't all be accepted for recycling
so be sure to check the number in the
triangle on the bottom so here in
southern nevada we take plastic number
one
number two and number five they have to
be some sort of bottle jug or tub so a
rigid plastic container
one and two are the most common you know
you're going to see that soda bottles
juice bottles water bottles
number two comes in many forms and
fashions whether it's a milk jug or a
tide detergent container
and then number five would be like a
sour cream tub
one two and five have the highest demand
for reprocessing into new products while
there are few markets if any in this
region for all the others and jeremy's
final piece of advice is to know before
you throw we have terms for that it's
called wish cycling or aspirational
recycling you know you may be standing
over your bin and holding something in
your hand and you feel that it should be
recyclable but you're not quite sure
don't just throw something in the bin
thinking hey you know what they'll
figure it out at the recycling center
that actually can do more harm than good
so when in doubt find out or simply when
in doubt throw it out
well i asked jeremy to grade southern
nevadans now on how well we're doing it
recycling on a scale of one to five
because we've been at this for a while
right
and he gave us a three
and he said there's always room for
improvement
so
you know recycling was going up we were
improving improving and then the
pandemic
and the numbers kind of came down
and so we need to go back up so we're
we're passing we're passing
we're not really in that a b category
we're getting a c and i think it's like
he said you know you just got to know
what's acceptable and how to throw it in
the big blue cart keep it all loose
don't bag your recyclables and look for
the arrows on the plastic bottles and
containers and tubs one two and five
said they take one two and five but if
you have a four does that mean you
should just throw it out yeah or find
another use for it a lot of times you
can take those containers and reuse them
for something
put a plant in them you know or use them
for potting or you know put them in your
pantry and put other stuff in them or
okay to put them in your laundry room
and use them but you know i reuse reuse
recycle um it's it's just however your
mindset is
to